never done drugs in my life I sell a lot
of it transport a lot of it
is what it is
all right coyote Cody uh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
I'm from 440 36 in St John in Brooklyn
from Brooklyn
New York what was your family like
well my mother I'm an only child my
mother was a cardiologist my dad was
oceanographer
the time I was 11 years old I was
already in 35 countries because my dad
my mother
my mother she was one of 14 surgeons
back in 1980 who put a pig heart in a
human
and he lived for six months and my
parents did not give a flying [ __ ] what
I did
and they put me in a voice Academy in
Oxford England a Naval Academy
and I ran away with a bunch of these
English kids and hopped trains and
that's how I learned how the hot trains
and listen to punk music
um and then my aunt she owned cbgb's
back home in New York
and
ever since then when I got out of the
Navy I was EOD at ltjg Lieutenant Junior
grade officer I got shot in my neck
right here
and it came out my face
and they want me on all these drugs and
[ __ ] and I was like no
trains for my PTSD and meditation
and I love it and I've been doing it for
30 years and I got five kids I raised
them I took them on my I took them on
trains I got two sets of twins Malachi
Jericho gag Evan engaged my daughter
she is she's a professional boxer Izzy
um you have an interesting family yeah
my mother's from Barcelona my dad's from
Italy so you think you're you're an only
child yeah my only child my mother had
to sign a waiver for for me to go in the
Navy do you think
yeah it sounds like your parents were
serious professionals yes and my mother
did not give a [ __ ] what I did about my
dad didn't give a [ __ ] what I did they
just like look just just imagine you
have a rope around your neck a noose you
[ __ ] up and hang yourself don't become
call on us so
I did what I did I was free do you think
having it I didn't have no rules do you
think having a set of parents that were
maybe a little more involved in your
life would have been better accepting of
my life the way I wanted to live yeah
I loved them
I still love them today but they're in
here but I love them
[Music]
so you how far did you in school
oh I graduated I went to college oh you
did yeah I I graduated in business
but what is it about train hopping that
that draws you
train hobby is free man like when them
brakes hit
it's like music
um
you could just see
things that you don't see on a highway
behind the mountains
are The Valleys or whatever
and
you're just out there I mean it's
it is like
your soul is like sitting beside you and
you're looking at everything around you
and you're just free
people Society
are trapped with all this [ __ ] around
them
and
it's all they know
I mean I've had people come up to me and
be like man I'll love your life
I wish I could do it I said you can do
it all you gotta do is pack and pack a
backpack and [ __ ] go say oh I got
kids and they're there they take them
with you I took my goddamn kids with me
I mean it is what it is I mean
people are distracting society and all
this government [ __ ] I mean
I ain't with it I live my life
Full Metal Jacket straight in them
goddamn check
love it chain hopping is dangerous huh
it is very dangerous
um I have took a lot of kids under my
wing and put them on a train
and I taught them but
they get too swelly and they end up
taking a piss in the train [ __ ] bucks
and off they go
I've seen a lot of kids die on trains
because they just don't listen like this
day in Era of kids at hop trains
it's not like back in the old days like
when I used to Hobbit
we used to just gets really sit down and
we had to take a piss we hold on to
[ __ ]
the rail you know and to have a [ __ ]
piss but or hang her asses off the side
of the [ __ ] The Boxcar or the Grainer
or whatever and take a [ __ ] you know but
these kids today they just want to
[ __ ] be ignorant and think they're
[ __ ] cool because they want to step
on the knuckle or run across it or
whatever
they don't have no clue they take it
because they hop one train they're train
Hoppers you know
so my partner crazy
I'm a teacher the right way out of hot
dreams
the proper way
and how to do [ __ ] the old school way
and how to read numbers on the side of
the electric boxes and [ __ ] because the
the numbers on the Ledger box will tell
you where you're at
that's the way the railroad is because
like a is one B is two you know C is
three I mean it's on down the uh the
alphabet
and you you see it and you mark it down
like okay this is where I'm at
now all these day and age they have crew
changes and these cell phones I don't I
hate cell phones I will never have a
cell phone and they get on there and
they look up where they're at and
everything no you got to remember
yeah I mean you could have the knowledge
and remember where you're at okay this
this is where I get off at or
or this is where I'm at or if you want
to stop off in a town that you have a
hot shot it's going through
a bunch of IMS uh double stackers the
trailers
um you put a rope inside the air brake
and you pull it out
and it sends a message up to the head
and
it stops the train and you hop off and
it goes
I mean it's easy
because they don't have a [ __ ] clue
of what's going on
do you end up going places that you
didn't plan on going to because uh
there's towns that I was like I was
hesitated to the Bell about going to
like a bunch of redneck ass towns but
uh you know what [ __ ] it
what I had to lose you know every state
I've been to every state
I've been in every state
um
I went into 35 countries time I was 11
years old and then when I went in the
Navy
I went to other countries and
I love it I went all over Europe with
these [ __ ] English kids helping
freight trains I mean loved it what have
you learned about people from all your
travels
well I tell you this
I work and travel
but when I can't work I will fly a sign
and now all the races
they kicked down money
the black people and the Mexicans
kicking most
white people
they don't do it they just look at you
and frown
but you know
it is what it is and they don't know
their history and what their ancestors
did back into the depression days
because they hopped great drains and
they bring money back
and a hobo means help other brothers out
or home rebound and they work and bring
money back a [ __ ] will travel but not
work
and a bomb a home bum is what you see
out here
or any City it stays in one town and
bumps change it won't travel not work or
anything
so
I'm proud to call myself a hobo
how do you support yourself panhandling
no I work I work and travel I work in
traveling when I came work what does
that mean
um I'll find a job
and I'll work for like a week or two and
get money up and go to my next spot oh I
see and I hate asking people for money
but when I can't find a job
I will for life I can sign I think I'll
Rusty your mother-in-law for fried
chicken or smack or pretend you know
but
it's the thing is it's like
this world today it's
it's the same as it was back then
is this repeating itself
and
this era of the day is late
all freaking out about [ __ ] hey this
[ __ ] happened years ago man I'm 52 years
old and
I'm gonna ride these goddamn real until
I die
mama oh it's your biggest fear my
greatest beer
my greatest fear
I don't have no fear
I've seen
I've been in combat
I did four tours in Iraq
and
I did
a tour
and Congo that
when I was young that creeped the [ __ ]
out of me
I I would rather do
more tours deployments to Iraq and then
what I did in Congo and I will not talk
about Congo
I cannot talk about Congo
but
Congo scared to living [ __ ] out of me
and [ __ ] gorillas
do you think you're just not cut out for
a more conventional lifestyle
I am who I am and if nobody assessed me
for who I am [ __ ] them
you pay taxes
[ __ ] no why
a
there's constitutional righteous we
don't have to pay taxes the only way we
pay taxes is because of the Treasury
Department
every time they print money
we had to pay that [ __ ] back it don't
matter
if we pay all of our [ __ ] debts out
to all these countries
we still had to pay taxes because every
time they borrow money we had to pay a
[ __ ] back the American people
do you do you think as a teenager you
had dreams of doing something similar to
this
yeah
you never dreamed about
um because because I went down to the
railroad tracks one time I was 11 years
old
I don't know 13 years old
and I met this oh hobo man he's just
sitting there and he just telling me
it's [ __ ] life and I was like man I
want to do this
so then
I was like you know what
I'm gonna do it
and then after that I went to that boys
Academy in England
are in in Oxford the Naval Academy and
met them kids and man I was like
I learned at a young age what to do and
what not to do and
if it wasn't for for them kids
[Music]
I would ever have freight trains
or that hobo that I met
his name was hobo Jim
you could look him up
he's a very famous man
but I think he's dead by now
what are your kids doing now
uh my kids are back well Malachi and
Jericho there in Barcelona where my
mother was born and raised uh they're
going to college
Gavin engaged is if Florence where my
dad was born and raised they're going to
college
my daughter Izzy she's a professional
boxer
and she's going to the University of
Miami
my VA pays for all their their college
and [ __ ] like that so
my kids are like
I told my kids I was like man I gotta go
back out I cannot stay in this house no
more I mean what do they think of Dad oh
they love me
I mean
I put them on a train
I put them in a car seat with a little
harness around their neck with the
uh gun speakers around their net or
their ears and a helmet on and strap
them in
put them on the back of a grinder and I
took all five of my kids on a train man
from New York
always a [ __ ] Louisiana from
Louisiana to Iowa from Iowa to Montana
from Montana back over to [ __ ]
um
North Dakota and then we headed back I
traveled with my kids I taught them I
taught them that
being
kind to people
you would be kind to yourself you know I
taught on the streets what to look for
and what to expect and said somebody
calling them I taught him this [ __ ]
and now they're book smart and they are
Street Smart
you got them Pew together you're a beast
what do you think most people
living a normal you know a
square life
are missing out on
spending time with their kids
spend time with their animals
I mean people shouldn't have kids
have a career that can't even spend have
nannies that take care of them
or leave their animals at home all year
you know I mean
you think we're all too busy chasing a
buck
all depend butchers you know when when
this world comes to when it's
it's coming
all right
all these people in these corporate
offices
you know who they're going to come to
they're gonna come to the streets and
ask for help
they didn't help us we ain't going to
help them
what's been your favorite memory in your
life
[Music]
my kids being born
yeah my kids
um
I've had a lot of favorite memories but
that's my most favorite memory
what was the roughest part of your life
my roughest part of my life
Congo
Congo is one of my roughest parts of my
life
because we spent two years over there
and
it was bad
but
there's a childhood oh
it's
flawless
loved it
wouldn't change it I wouldn't change my
life if somebody paid me a million
dollars right now
I tell them to stick in her [ __ ] ass
and go
I would
money ain't nothing it ain't backed by
nothing this is a [ __ ] piece of paper
plain and simple
do you have any advices any drugs
alcohol or anything like that uh I drink
I drink but I have cut down a very very
very light I usually drink three half
gallons of liquor a day
and
I know my health is
not very well but I do exercise and take
care of myself but
I do drink
and uh
I think I think one right now sure
but uh
I like tequila and
Crown Royal is my shed I can't drink no
low shelf [ __ ]
do not do vodka because I will end up in
prison me and bucket does not get along
cheers of the world
big one
Space Bags
so burnt out on them
a space bag is a box of wine
back in the day the bag you used to be
silver
now they're clear
and I am so burnt out of them we we use
this to get them and spill them and blow
them up so uh the girls on the train
would sew them up with dental floss and
we make an air mattress out of them or a
pillow or whatever
but
I love my life
and
my kids are taken care of they're set
I had to worry about nothing
and
they tell me he's like pops go do what
you want to do you raised us is what it
is so
I'm doing it
I'm living Dad's life right now
I took care of them it's my time
if you had your life to live all over
again would you do anything differently
[ __ ] no
I love it
what is it or not I love the about break
dreams
you wanna go on a train with me so
you've traveled around Europe the same
way you travel in the U.S yeah how is it
different U.S in Europe I like Europe
better
I think you're better
like the laws and government [ __ ] over
there it's it's way better here there it
is
their fingers are in our [ __ ] and
they just want to make [ __ ] money
I mean every time you you buy something
or whatever you [ __ ] do you're just
lining the government's [ __ ] pocket
they're so [ __ ] corrupt
I mean I just wish they would wipe them
out you know
it's actually the American people's
fault because the president we [ __ ]
have now but I don't do politics or
religion
you know I tell people why did Jesus
walk on water and they'll say why I was
like because [ __ ] floats you know
because I'm not a religious man I don't
care what the [ __ ] you believe in but it
is what it is I mean whatever you
believe in believe in it if you believe
in this government [ __ ] believe in it
but you know what you are a free-range
person this is a free country you have
soldiers who have fought for this
country like myself freedom is not free
it is what it is live your [ __ ] life
do not be under these people's fingers
I think the United States biggest
problem is
our government
our government [ __ ] yeah our
government
I mean look you got veterans on the
street
a veteran shouldn't be on a goddamn
Street he should never go hungry
he needs to be the person on the line
but our government won't take care of us
they they want us to you know
Uncle Sam that man on that sign for the
military hey we need you you know he was
a meat packer
that man was actually a meat Packer that
was a real guy so my philosophy of [ __ ]
is is that
they pack us out as meat and bring us
back
as me
and the definition you never leave a
brother behind
I mean if if you see your your fellow
Soldier behind your brother beside you
I don't give a [ __ ] of his fingernail I
don't give a [ __ ] it was this nut sack
you put that [ __ ] in your pocket you
bring it back home it never leave a
brother behind that's the definition
and the thing is is like I am so tired
of this goddamn country
I know I served it
and
if anything ever happened I would do it
again
but the thing is is I'm gonna get the
[ __ ] out of this country
because [ __ ] is getting [ __ ] crazy
coyote what would you say is the most
important lesson you learn in your life
respect
respect
respect for others
who give respect
you know
um
you know
I always give the people a benefit of
doubt I don't judge I don't give a [ __ ]
their own heroin they drink they
they're gay they're transgender or
whatever the [ __ ] they are
[Music]
I don't give a [ __ ]
but the thing is
you don't touch a kid
you don't put your hands on a woman and
you don't beat a dog
you do that around me I don't give a
[ __ ] who you are I don't know you or
whatever
I'm gonna step in and I want to take
care of it
Obama and
and I have staff people in their [ __ ]
necks and bodies and [ __ ] like that for
[ __ ] with kids and women or beating
their [ __ ] dogs like a lot of train
hoppers
they get all cracked out on drugs and
they want to beat their [ __ ] dogs hey
I'll beat the [ __ ] out of them take
their goddamn dogs and give them to a
Goddamn good family
I mean
like I transported this one lady it was
getting beat by her husband
with a newborn
on a train
so I didn't put her on a boxcar or a
Grainer or anything like that put her in
a unit where it'd be quiet for that
child
and I took her where she needed to go
and I dropped her off
so
you know a lot of people look at me like
I'm crazy because of my tattoos and my
face but
I don't show my aggression until my
aggression needs to be said
if somebody ever put their hands on
my traveling partner or disrespected her
or anything like that
it's over
I'll check them one time they don't
listen it's on
I only give one
sometimes I don't even get none
depends what the situation is
but I am a dictated bear
I take care of kids I do get a VA
don't get much from them
but
I do get VA from them and I take that
money take care of my kids on the rails
if they need shoes if any clothes
whatever the [ __ ] you need I'll buy it
for them I would I've gave a couple of
them some money but
I've always buy it to make sure that
they [ __ ] get it
but I take care of my family on these
roads there's there's probably over
man
it's probably over 30 000 kids
it helped great dreams
because you know they don't want to live
at home with their families I mean like
their dads might be creepos or
they don't like the rules of mommy
Daddy's house or Mommy Daddy's too
strict but
they just want to be themselves and be
free
I mean they found their path and they
want to take it and live the life and
then later on in life when they get
older
if they make it to odor live fast diely
young but you know but the thing is is
like
they
people just need to be free man
that's all
just be free in life
help each other you know I mean it is
what it is it ain't no [ __ ] hippie
but I do help people
I mean
like I was in
Walmart
in Lancaster
he said let me guess California
yeah and I was just walking through and
I was getting some food and stuff
and this Mexican kid the Pedro he wanted
his Lego set like this pirate Lego said
it was like 100 or something bucks
and and the mother was like oh no no no
no no I seen that [ __ ] so I grabbed it
walked all the way to front with all my
stuff
I paid for it I waited for him
there you go Pedro
the mother looked at me
she couldn't speak much English but I
speak Spanish and Italian I keep proper
Spanish because my mother Barcelona
and she was like oh thank you single I
think you're saying that then you're I
was like hey just pass it Forward she
said I can't pay you one I was like
whatever
I don't care
I made that kids day
that's all the small things in life will
make a person happy
and that's what you have to learn
all right coyote thank you so much for
sharing your story
but I want to do one more thing before I
go
I stole a yacht
back home in New York
and this goddamn bracelet your ankle
bracelet
it's driving me [ __ ] nuts I know I'm
gonna be wanted I don't care I'm outlaw
so this is what I'm gonna do I'm going
to donate this [ __ ] bracelet to you
and I'll keep your knife sharp woman
and I will sign it
fought the government
what is it
these are heavy